心は物質の中に依存して生活しているんですね
そこで我々はもう大きな巨大な物質を見ているだけで
あの心はすごく成長しちゃうと
巨大な物質ではなくて
原子レベルの物質とか素粒子のレベルの物質とか認識することが可能なんです
それでもっと次元の違う物質でも認識することが可能なんです
ですから このルーパアヴァチュル次元に色界ですから
色界のところに入ったら
原子顕微鏡なくても見ようとすれば見られるし
聞こうとすれば聞こえるし
そういう能力も出てくるんです
ですから この仏教で言ってる神通力の話とか
全部ここから出てくるんです
でもここからはもう一般の心理学とはもう何の関係もない
一般の心理学では いろんな人々にいろんな能力があるでしょ
超能力みたいなもの それ説明できませんから
でも現象だけを扱ってますね
例えば これから起こる起こる起ころうとしているものは
ある人にすぐ見えてしまうとかあるし
違うところに 例えば自分の子供がアメリカに行けとか
何かひどい目に遭うようになっちゃうとあったならば
その同時にその時間に同じ時間で日本にいる母親がなんとなくわかってしまっちゃうとか
そういう現象はいくらでも世の中であるんです
いわゆるその場合は 母親は距離的に日本にいる
子供はアメリカにいる
でもシムルテーニアスに認識が生まれてくる
いっぺんに 子供が何かひどい目に遭っちゃうし
それに対する母の反応ですか
すぐここに生まれちゃうし
同じ時間で そういうのはケーススタディとして集めて
いくらでもテキストはありますけど
じゃあ説明してくれと
説明は不可能なんですね
で 仏教ではそういう説明はまあそれほど難しくはないんです
で あの まあ一応ついでに方法は言いますけど
簡単に もし我々にできれば
瞬間でも私というこの実感を瞬間でもいいんです
忘れることできれば 忘れて認識すると
できれば違うこの超越した認識っていうのはすぐ生まれるんです
そこをどうやって忘れるかっていうのは
これ大変なんです ただそれだけなんです
その 例えば母親が子供のことを感じたって言うならば
その瞬間で我という実感は消えちゃう
消える瞬間なんです たまに人々にあるんです
それは ただ自分ということじゃなくて
なんかボケっとしてもう認識しちゃうとかね
自分でもわからない 普通だったら私は聞きました
私は見ましたという実感でしょ
それだったら次元はもう欲界だけなんです
私の何もなく 何か見えたという感じですからね
ですから その瞬間で私という土台から認識したわけじゃないんです
ですから みんな何か変なことを言うんですね
いきなり見えましたとかなどとか
神からもうなんか好きだったとかとかとか
もうなぜならば自分の意識がそこで働いてないんですね
自分で見たわけじゃなくて
見えただけ 自分で聞いたわけじゃなくて
聞こえただけ ですから
そういう人々は説明しようとするとすっごくおかしい説明しちゃうんですね
別におかしいことなんともないんです
たまたま自我を忘れただけ
自我忘れた瞬間の認識は
現代に人間みんな特別な能力として
超能力として あるいは心理学ではどんな言葉で使っているのか
この ESP ESP として Extrasensory Perception というんですね
で扱っているんです それは Extrasensory ではないんです
ESP は日本語の訳ありますか？何かありますか
一般的に超能力というものなんですけどね
Extrasensory というのはSenseというのは五根
眼耳鼻舌身という五処ですね Extra
っていうのはそれに関係なく認識しましたと
でも我々頭で考えることも
その定義に基づくならばエクストラセンサリーなんですね
なぜならば ヨーロッパではセンスというのは
既婚というのは眼耳鼻舌身だけだから
五根だけだから だからヨーロッパの心理学も結構定義は曖昧といえば曖昧でもいい加減なんです
もし既婚五根しか認めてないならば
頭で考えるものはね 妄想の世界
思考の世界 全部エクストラセンサリーでしょうに
人間堂々と考えているでしょうに
そういう部分 そこら辺は抜けているんですね
ヨーロッパの心理学は
それは説明しないで認めるんですね
考えることは そこに魂入れちゃう
私がいて魂がいてそんなことやってるんだ
だからまあそんなに だからヨーロッパの定義に基づいで仏教定義改編する必要またないんです
ヨーロッパ的な知識を持って
まあどこでも誰でもかなり曖昧いい加減で
抜け穴というのはいっぱいあるんです
じゃあエクストラセンサリーではなくて
それはこの自我意識がない瞬間で生まれるパーセプションなんですね
仏教から説明するならば
ですから まあ非自己的認識だと何とか言った方が超能力ではなくてね
ですから 皆さんもちょっと頑張ってみてください
この自分で見る聞くということは
何か内容に何か認識することができるかどうかとかね
まあ具体的に 例えば今聞いてるでしょ
自分で じゃなくて 音に耳
どんな音で耳に触れても流してあげるとかね
いわゆる聞こえるようにしてやる
置くだけ 自分では聞こうとしない
似ていることをヴィパッサナーでもやってますけどね
でも誰にも超能力は生まれませんしね
それ生まれないようにいろいろ工夫しているんです
生まれたらもう悟れなくなっちゃうんですね
欲張りばっかりだから
煩悩いかに固定させようということでヴィパッサナーもやってるんです
それ知ってるんです 別にこの煩悩をなくそう
悟るという気持ちでやってるやっているわけじゃないんです
いろいろ世の中でいろんな苦しみを味わって
この苦しみを消しちゃって
すごく楽をしたいという欲でやってるんだから
そこは人に言ったっても理解しないんですね
ですから まあここら辺で
こちら側でそこら辺何か工夫して
とことんひどい目にだけ遭わせて
煩悩が消えるように施術する
しなきゃもう悟れないんですね
ですから ヴィパッサナーではまあ稀な人でない限り
やっぱり欲がもともとからも少ない人でない限りは特別な能力はつけないんです
もともとからの欲が少なく
真理を知りたく 心を清らかにしたくという気持ちは本気である場合は無意識的にある場合はね
意識的には私というのはそうですよって言うかもしれませんだけどね
無意識にはコントロールできませんからね
無意識的にない場合は生まれてこないんです
ですから この一応音は聞くんじゃなくて放っておく
ものは見るんじゃなくて放っておくと勝手に見えてる
そういうふうな訓練で
何か違うものを見えたり聞こえたりする可能性はあります
ですから よく聞いて情報をデータ見てください
この何か見えた聞こえたという人々が
全然見たく見たわけじゃない
聞こえたく聞こえたわけじゃないんです
その瞬間で 何か幽霊見たい見たい見たいなと思って見たわけじゃなくて
たまたま見えたと 何のことなく
その瞬間で自我意識が消えただけで
そういうふうな もうちゃんとした合理的な説明あるんです
そういう現象には ですから
この今 いろんな人にイエス様を見ているみたいんですけど
みんな世紀末論とかああだこうだとかね
もう何て言いますか 妄想だらけの世界になってますけどね
そんな現象っていうのは今だけじゃなくて
昔からあったんです 昔の人々はそんなに大胆に世紀末論だとか
たったもうそろそろ 2000年になるだけのことで
そんな大げさなことじゃないでしょうに
日本だけノストラダムスかなんとかという人のテキストを信仰したりとかね
日本だけなんです 誰もあまり相手にしてないんです
そこで自分勝手に解釈する
あの人何言ったかわかりませんだから
たまにその人はもしかすると自我のない瞬間の何かボケとした経験に色々あったかもしれません
自分見たことはそれなりに何か言ったかもしれません
だからといって それはその通りで
具体的に現代に起こるかとか
そんな話は全く関係ないし
それからまた全部解釈だから
どうでもいいことで  2000年になったら世紀末ね
まあ世紀末か 言葉通りに言えば世紀末ですけど
まあそれだけのことなんですよ
1999年が 2000年になるだけ
イエスが現れてきて 世界は全部終わりにするというのは
それは教会の誤りであって誤って誤解して計算しただけであって
遠い昔なんですね 世紀末になって世界の終わりになると教会が計算していたのは
その日にちはもうとっくに昔飛んで行っちゃったんです
ですから そういうのは人間のただの妄想だらけの話で
そういう風な この特別に何か見えたり聞こえたりするという現象が世の中でずっとあるものなんです
この最近科学発展したんだから
超能力という言葉で扱ってみんな驚いてるんだけで
昔は驚かなかったんですね
そういう差だけ ですから
まあどんな人にでもそういう能力はつけようと思えばつけるもんなんです
このルーパヴァチャラチッタというその心が
ですから ある訓練によって生まれる
仏教で言えば瞑想によって生まれる認識なんですね
瞑想というのはどうしてごく普通の日常的なやり方ではないんです
まあちょっと違うやり方で認識の力を強くするんです
で あの説明一番しやすい
あの やり方 どうでもどんな方法でもいいんです
認識さえ超越するならば
で いろんな方法があります
どんな瞑想法でもいいんです
日本の真言密教とかそういう宗教にある瞑想でもいいし
もうキリスト教の瞑想でもいいし
どんな瞑想でも構いません
一般的な認識のやり方と変えた方法であれば
それで十分です このフルパワースポットを作るためには
で まあ一応その中で 特にインドではいろんな瞑想をたくさん見ましたからね
その中からこの誤解しにくい
それから悟りには迷惑にならない
かえって助けになる瞑想だけ厳密に選んで
このサマタ瞑想として仏教では種類のサマタ瞑想を教えているんです
サマーディを作る瞑想
禅定を作る瞑想種類ぐらい注釈書ではまとめているんです
その瞑想対象に これ今日このパーリの言葉を覚えてください
カッマッターナと読むんです
瞑想対象にはカッマッターナという言葉使っているんです
で カッマはよく使ってますけど
業ですけどね でもこの場合は業じゃないんです
だからこの言葉に気をつけないと
ものすごい大変なことになります
この場合は この行為 働き
仕事っていう意味なんですね WORK
という意味で意味なんです
カッマ 何か仕事をするということで
ターナっていうのは場所を意味するんです
場所か 仕事自体かその意味するんです
ですから このカッマッターナ
宗教から関係なく パーリ語の言葉
一般パーリ語だと勘違いして直訳するならば
これは仕事っていう意味なんです
それから事務所という言葉でも使えるんです
カッマッターナっていうのは
一般パーリ語だったら
仕事か事務所かどっちかなんです
でもこの場合は これは宗教的な意味で使っているんです
ですから このその時の仕事なんですね
種類仕事あって その仕事一つ選んでやると
心のレベルが調子ちゃうと
ですから ヴィパッサナー瞑想にはヴィパッサナーカッマッターナと言うんです
だから その仕事なんです
ヴィパッサナーという仕事をすると
悟りということが得られると
サマタという仕事をすると
超越した禅定という認識が生まれるんだ
ですから 仕事を与えてくれる先生にはカンマッターナ・アチャーリヤというんです
瞑想指導者に そういうのはまあ決まってる用語で
で ミャンマーに行った経験がある方々はよくその言葉を使うのが耳に入ったと思います
瞑想指導者にはみんなにカンマッターナ・アチャーリヤと言うんです
いわゆるアチャーリヤの先生だから
その先生が仕事を与えてくれる
こういう仕事をしなさい
そこでやった仕事はチェックする
うまくやったかないか
もし仕事を失敗したならば
それでまたこうじゃなくて
こういう風にしなさいと
ですから 仕事の監督ということでね
カンマッターナ・アチャーリヤと言うんです
大変この まあ尊敬されている立場なんです
カンマッターナ・アチャーリヤになった
私はそうじゃないんですけど
で ですから 瞑想する人は完全にカンマッターナ・アチャーリヤという先生に従わなくちゃいけない
喧嘩してはいけない 逆らってはいけない
頭下げて年下であろうがもうしょうがないんです
ただ 年上のお坊さんが年下のお坊さんから瞑想指導を受ける場合は
その場合に限ってだけ
仏教では年下の人に頭下げなくちゃいけないんです
仏教はすごい厳しいんだから
しきたりなんか年上のお坊さんはもう徹底的に年上で偉いんですが
カンマッターナを受ける場合は
その場合でも捨てなくちゃいけないんです
そういうふうに厳しくしているんです
一応こういうよく出会う言葉だから
瞑想する場合 覚えた方がいいんです
瞑想対象 あるいは瞑想という仕事はカンマッターナと呼ぶんです
そこでこの心の認識レベルを大きく高くする
超越する場合はカンマッターナは種類があるんだと
種類あるんです その種類というのは仏教の注釈層でまとめている種類で
それだけという意味じゃないんです
この まあわかりやすく言えば
この神秘体験があるという話があるんで
世の中 もし仕事をして
何かに何かお祈りとか何とかして
何か神秘体験があったら
それもカンマッターナの一つなんです
何のこともしないのに神秘体験があったというならば
その人にはもう結構もうよく自分が抜ける人で
もうボケしてる人で たまたまもう自分という自我意識が抜けちゃった瞬間で何か体験したということで
それで神秘体験だと言うんです
別に神秘体験じゃない
神秘じゃないんです 何かあるものを見るだけなんです
だから嘘でもないんです
完全に なんで選んだかというと
このこの瞑想の世界っていうのは
もう徹底的にこの誤解しやすい世界なんです
一番誤解を生まれやすいのは瞑想の世界なんです
分かりやすく説明すると
例えばこの部屋の中にライオンがいるんだと
実際にはライオンがいないんです
皆様はいつでも自我意識があるんだから
まあこっちライオンがいるのは見えますかと聞いても見えません
嘘だと とんでもない話だと
もし私はある人に暗示かける
暗示かけてとことん深く暗示かけて
彼の自我意識を全部コントロールする
自分で見せたり 聞こえたりする
聞かせたりする 深く暗示かけた人にこの部屋の中に今ライオンがいますと入ってきたんだ
それでもいくらか論理的に言わなくちゃ暗示かけられません
あの誰かドアが開けたんです
今音を聞こえたでしょうと
だからはい 聞こえたってその人に音を聞こえる
あれ ライオンが連れてくるんだ
すごい大きなライオンですねと聞いたら
そうですねとか 怖いですねとか
ほんと怖くて もう暗示かけたらそういうことあり得るんです
そのどうなりますかというと
やっぱりそれはその人の自我意識をこのある人にコントロールされちゃうんです
自我意識抜きに認識したりする
その生まれた時から この母体の中の経験とか
この暗示かけちゃって体験させちゃうでしょ
それは嘘じゃない 簡単なんです
そこであり得てもしないライオンが直接あると目で見えて体験して怖くなると
そこまでできるんだから
そこは嘘なんですね 本当はライオンはいないんだから
だから自我意識ない時生まれる経験が
嘘か本当か知る方法がなくなっちゃうんです
暗示かけてなんかこの
感情でもこれはもう火傷するぐらい熱いですよと言って触らせちゃったら
ものすごくもう手が火傷しちゃうんだから
いくらかでも火傷しちゃいますから
ですから 瞑想に対してはすっごく気をつけなくちゃいけない
で 例えばマリア様を見ますとかね
まあこれはいっぱい現代やってる瞑想なんですけど
マリア様見たくて ジェズス様見たくて
一生懸命瞑想する で 目には見えませんだけど
もう見える場合はあると仮定すると
じゃあだからそれ信じつかないかと
何の証拠もないんです
なぜならばライオンを見せることはできるんです
暗示かけちゃって だから自己暗示かけて何でも体験すること
あるものも体験できるし
ないものも体験できる
そういう大変なことだから
全くあり得もない幻覚ばっかり体験しちゃったら
その人はもう頭狂ってる状態でしょうに
ですから 瞑想する人はすっごく気をつけなくちゃいけない
かすかにでも暗示かけてはいけない
あまりインパクトが入れてもう話しかけてはいけないんです
みんなに嫌われますけど
僕が言ってるようにやってみればどうかな
どうなるかっていうことは言っておかないとか
最初からテキストか作ってあげて
このテキスト通りにやってみてくださいって言っちゃったら
本物か偽かっていうのは誰にもわからなくなっちゃうんです
どんな立派な瞑想修行者にも
もう手に負えなくなっちゃうんです
ですから 危ないところはこの幻覚体験するところだけなんです
幻覚は幻覚であるとわかったらもういいんだけど
人っていうのはそれほど柔軟性じゃない
ものすごい もうもともと頑固だから
俺が見たんだからという状態で言っちゃいますから
私にもたまに人が話しちゃうと
いろいろそういう経験があったとかね
イエス様が見えましたとか
最近言われた人がいましたけど
言われる瞬間に僕はこの人はもうカットと
ただ話して それでよかったんではないかで終わって
その人はもうカットだと
この人に仏教も教えてあげて
講演に参加したっても
仏教を教えてあげて理解してほしいという気持ちさえないんです
その代わりに自分の仕事を通して無視してはいけないんだから
一応あなたはなんのことない
ただのバカですよということだけは間接的には言うんです
それで終わるんです でも指導して育ててあげようというところはいかないんです
なぜならば もうもしかするともう手を越え状態かもしれません
人間は目で 目で見たものについてはもうそうじゃないよと言っちゃったら
いくらかそうかというぐらいになりますけど
ああいう風にこの変なものを見ちゃったら
もう徹底的にそれを信じちゃう
それは人間が持っている一般的な弱みなんです
心の そこら辺を理解しないで瞑想を教えるということは
大変無責任な仕事なんです
ですから 仏教の瞑想をしなさいと僕らは堂々と言うのは
お釈迦様はものすごくその心の働きを知っていて
ものすごい責任を持って指導しているんだから
それぐらい責任を持ってるという話を
僕はいろんな宗教の瞑想は読んだり聞いたりしたんだけど
もう全然責任持ってない
とことん人に暗示かけてかけてかけて
もうもう神様はもうこの目の前で救ってあげようとかね
ある宗教家の話を聞いたところでも
もうものすごいマインドコントロール
徹底したアメリカ人なんですけど
徹底的にもうマインドコントロールしちゃうんです
徹底的にマインドコントロールして
もう神様がこうだとか言っちゃう
そこでもう普通の人間だから聞いて頭が狂ってしまっちゃうんですね
狂う頭狂っても世の中狂ってると認めない
なぜならば神様体験するんだから
ありがたいんですね 私もそうなりたいですとみんな思っちゃうだけ
そこで文化的に神という概念というのは
ヨーロッパ文化では大変ありがたい概念なんですね
神を信じるということは
道徳を守る 信頼できる立派な人という意味なんですね
英語だったら別に神様は存在しているんですよという意味というよりは
一般英語だったら道徳的な
信頼できる正直な人間という意味なんです
ですから そういう文化的な背景がありますから
神様を体験したということをありがたがっちゃうんです
そういうことで この仏教にはやっぱり選ぶことになってしまったんです
40種類の瞑想 その中で仏教だけで作った瞑想もいくつかあります
この不浄観 徹底的にこの体は臭くて醜くて汚いものだと瞑想する
それから死の瞑想 自分が瞬間瞬間も死んでいるんだと
何瞬間でも私はいるということはないんだ
ただの死の過程だけです
死死死死だけの流れに生きているということを言っているんだという死の瞑想
それは仏教だけの瞑想ですね
不浄観と死の瞑想 それからこの念仏がありますね
念仏 ブッダを念じること
念仏というのは日本語では別に不思議な言葉じゃないんだから
念仏も当たり前ですけど
仏教だけの瞑想なんですが
それは 他の宗教から仏教入れて入れ替えたものなんです
いわゆる神を念じることはあったんだから
他の宗教で 神様をどんな神様でもいいし
関係なくこの他の宗教にはあるんですね
神を念じること それによって心は統一して禅定状態が生まれてくる
ですから その方法をまた仏教に入れて
神を念じるんじゃなくて
ブッダを念じなさい その中で念仏といえば
日本では南無阿弥陀仏一つですけど
テーラワーダではこれすっごくもう複雑なんです
簡単じゃないんです テーラワーダではブッダを念じる場合はブッダの徳を念じるんです
そこでまた優れているんです
阿弥陀仏 阿弥陀仏と言っちゃうと
ある個人を念じることになっちゃうんですね
そうすると他の宗教の神を念じることと同じくなっちゃうんです
仏教のテーラワーダの念仏っていうのは
ブッダの徳を念じる 徳はいっぱいあるんです
その中で自分に理解できる徳をとって
それを念じる 例えば一番有名なのは人気あるのは人気第一はこのお釈迦様の九徳
ミャンマー風に言えば十徳なんですけど
正しいものは九徳なんです
お釈迦様の徳は九つありまして
それで自分に理解できる一つをずっと観察する
で 今日ちょっと紹介しますけど
一つだけ皆様に分かりやすいこと
お釈迦様には天人師と言うんですね
それ徳の九つの中で一つなんです
サッターデーマヌッサナ
天人の神々と人間の偉大なる師であると
それを観察する 簡単な方はブッダは天人師である
天人師ですと念じることなんですね
その念じていっちゃうと
どんどん自分の心がブッダに対するすごい尊敬と信仰というものをどんどん増やしてくる
それは一番簡単なレベル低いやり方なんですけど
で 信仰が増やしてくるとどうなるかというと
もう天人師は 生命の師はブッダしかないというぐらいに納得いってしまっちゃって
それでお釈迦様がおっしゃることは
そのまま何も抵抗なく心に受け入れることできるようになっちゃうんです
それでお釈迦様がおっしゃっている人間が徹底的に抵抗する論理ありますよ
無常と無我と空ということ
それは何の抵抗もなく心に入っちゃう
それで悟りに行ってしまうんです
ですから この念仏する瞑想っていうのは
そんなレベル高い瞑想じゃないんだけど
どんな宗教にもある瞑想ですけど
そういう風に工夫して仏教で使っている
でもっとレベルいい知識的な天人師の瞑想は
釈尊は本当に人間神々の師ですかと
いかなるものかと自分が観察してみる
釈尊の教えとか読んでみて
それはどのように工夫しているんですかとか
どのような人間に分かるようにしているんですかとか
こんな深い内容はわかってしまいますよ
こんなに深い内容はこんなにわかりやすくよくもおっしゃってるんだと
ただ 私のやり方はそういうやり方でしたから
本当に驚くんですね よくもこんなに難しいこと
こんな単純な言葉で また欠けた言葉一つもないし
余計な言葉一つもない
あれ不思議なんですね
例えば僕の話じゃったら
余計な言葉 99%あって
必要な言葉 1%にもないぐらいだから
だからどうでもいい詩なんですね
あってもなくてもあまり損はないしな
んですけど 釈迦尊の言葉一つ取ったら
どんな言葉もかけて取った方がいいかと
絶対絶対見つからないはずなんです
ものすごい言葉を選ぶ時でも
余計な言葉一つも選ばない
例えば ある言葉をちょっと強調しちゃうと
それはまさにその場で強調しなくちゃいけない
そういう風に ごく普通の知識人らしく経典を読んだり
お釈迦様の能力を発見しようと
師として 先生として この個人のお釈迦様を見つかろうと
生きていたお釈迦様を経典を通って見つかろうと思っちゃうと
それも念仏なんです そこで偉大なる存在は見つかる
そこはもう必ずその悟りの方向へ行っちゃうんです
やっぱりまあ 煩悩はなくすべきものだよというぐらいには人が来るんです
全然幻覚は生まれません
で それに付け加えて 念仏だけではなくて
だから念仏の場合も九つありますよ
九つの徳を念じるんだから
今説明したのはたった一つだけ
この分かりやすく誰にでもできる方法で
ミャンマータワーとかやっているのは
お釈迦様一番目のアラハンという徳なんです
それは仏教信者さんには簡単にできるんです
お釈迦様が先生であることはもう全然話にならない
そんな問題にならないんです
瞑想対象にならない もう信仰あるんだから
お釈迦様以外何も信じませんだから
ですから そんなにインパクト
インパクトのある瞑想対象にならない
その代わりにアラハンということは
仏教のテーラワーダの信者さんに対してはすごい言葉なんです
アラハンという言葉 お釈迦様はなぜ偉いかというと
阿羅漢になったんだから偉いんです
そうでないと普通の人間でしたから
ですから このありとあらゆる方法でアラハンという言葉を瞑想しますよ
念仏として で それが今
上座仏教の信者さんに人気ある瞑想
皆様にできる瞑想ってもうわかりやすくできるのは
もしかすると私は勝手に決めたものなんですけど
違うものかもしれません
だけど 念不至とかそういうとこ
ですから 念仏する中でも九つがあります
それから次にあるのは念法
法を念じる瞑想 それも仏教だけの瞑想なんですね
法を念じるということは
もうそれはまた簡単と言えば簡単なんですね
仏教を勉強してみるんです
とことん 頭の中で全てのものを仏教の角度で見てみようとする
あの鳥が捕まった時と同じく
喋るとこは私は行きますと言ってもいいんだけど
真面目にここに私がいないんだと
分からなくてもいいんです
あるのは色受想行識だけですよ
人を見たら これは色受想行識ですと
動物見たらああ 可愛い犬だよって
そんなことじゃない それ欲ですからね
色五蘊 五蘊だ そういう風に頭の中で人に言わない
瞑想だから人に言っちゃったら
もうこの人おかしいではないかと言われるんだからね
瞑想だから頭の中でそういう風に
この念法 念法は念法 それでもう一つ
念想 念想の瞑想 今日瞑想の説明じゃないんだけど
まあ一応この仏教の瞑想の世界はものすごい幅広いんです
ヴィパッサナーにもいろいろ方法あるんです
自分にちゃんと適した方法を選ばないと効果はないというか
すごい遅いというか たった一つの方法だけもうコマーシャル的にして売るんじゃないんです
そんな 2500年ずっと来ている伝統だからね
偉大なるシステムです
で 念想の場合は やっぱりこのそれも分かりやすいところから始めてもいいし
私の立場から言うなれば
この偉大なる阿羅漢たちのことを観察してみる
そういうのはちゃんとテキストいっぱいありますし
勉強できるし 真剣に勉強すると
その人々が自分の心の中に現れてくるんです
私は知識すごく好きな性格のとんでもない性格かもしれませんだけど
生まれちゃったんだから
性格はしょうがないんだから
自分でわざわざ作ったものじゃないんだから
で 阿羅漢第八 八十人の阿羅漢の中で
やっぱりいつでも気にいるのは
気に入ってるのはサーリプッタ尊者ですか
知恵の第一と言われている
ですから 自分にとってはサーリプッタ尊者の思考方向やら考え方やら生活やら
もう全部この手に取って
[背景音楽]